[Music]
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to a special midweek
quarantine episode of life is short
hosted by me justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Applause]
[Music]
and with me as always is my brother my
uh equally quarantined brother
christian
you know both of me quarantined together
we want to get into
uh everything so many things to talk
about so many things oh my goodness
where do we begin
um yeah a lot of things going on but uh
the one thing on everybody's mind is
christian how are you
um so justin nation is wondering so on
our first special quarantine episode
justin and i mentioned that
we uh are
both coveted sufferers we
think i mean you definitely are yes um
we have to now be very careful what we
say because uh well anyway that us
saying that has uh generated
news
which that's fair to say yeah i mean it
was in fact i was getting texts from
it was very you know it was very
flattering i was getting texts from
people i i before i knew that it was a
story that had been picked up i was
hearing from friends and who who did you
hear from people who were checking in to
make sure you're okay so this was a
story that it was on daily mail
usa today
e news it was all over the place yeah
not a single person
reached out to mysteries
really nobody no i mean they didn't
people were already reaching out to me
people who
care about me yeah the people that you
and so those were probably the people
that you cared about respects right like
people i went to high school with that i
haven't talked to in 20 years right you
know i mean i guess i kind of did expect
that yeah why not i'm not saying like i
got it it was like a deluge of you got
what three people three
three people but i also after i realized
it was a story that was out there i um
i texted you know the key people that
and the people that like you're also not
on facebook so right people
have to reach out to you directly yeah
and um
but you know we should put something
maybe on instagram where we just let
people know how we're doing and we can
do that now how are you doing
i'm doing a lot better i i still have
some lingering stuff in my chest
some issues yeah it scares me every time
i hear you cough a little bit only
because we're bombarded with this you
know all the horrific news that's going
on and i've heard some stories where it
can take a turn and
um but you seem to have what kind of
never mind no um but
you seem very
it just feels like a lingering thing i
i'm certainly um
in a much better position than a lot of
people who get this luckily yeah i will
say if we if i did have it um a mild
version of it i feel very fortunate you
seem fine yeah i'm fine i am fine i feel
healthy and maggie is fine maggie's
completely recovered um
uh we're still quarantined we're still
being uh responsible i hope everyone
who's able um is doing the same thing
staying home uh but but yeah it's it's
we i i will count myself among the very
lucky ones if i if i did get it um
and i know there's a test coming out and
we're gonna call our doctor friends so
dave kessler dr dave kessler who will be
much more informative than i would also
he goes away doctor no i know i know i
said that
dr k but first we're going to check in
with our friend a friend of the show
uh mr gerry o'connell she's not a
licensed medical practitioner no bear
keep that in mind
give me a break
he was upset last time i talked to him
that we hadn't called him yet uh because
you know he has a in his defense he's a
teacher now he that's right oh my god
let's see
how jerry o'connell's doing jerry uh if
you follow him on instagram you'll see
that he's been
as many people have been uh
homeschooling their kids
with hilarious results uh max
greenfield's very funny person to follow
sorry the mailbox is full
oh man
uh okay
oh here's jerry
jerry o'connell
oh wait hold on
wait why okay
i missed his
entrance i think he was like a hey hey
it was his it was his podcast greeting
oh boy
just hang up that phone
what
hanging up hey you you can say hi to
justin if you want yeah yeah is that
charlie dolly
it was it was my wife oh how's rebecca i
want to say hi to rebecca
um she's uh
eating lunch sorry buddy hey um
that thing that you put on instagram
with the uh dog collar
jerry jerry posted very instead of
rebecca a very funny video of um
jerry trying on it
that we had
yeah was that an old video
well yes we had a dog um that um
the neighbors were complaining was
barking nonstop oh god and they were
threatening to call the police and all
that sort of stuff
this is in calabasas
so we purchased something that sprayed
citronella spray and that did nothing
it's sprayed it where onto the dog it's
just like there's it's like a scent of
citronella spray so like um oh like that
the dog barks and like it squirts out
citronella it's supposed to be a little
more yeah like a pavlovian response
yeah it's supposed to be a little more
convenient
right
enjoyed the taste of the smell of
citronella
right and then um
so we got the shocker one but before we
put it on the dog my wife wanted me to
try it out
and so um
i put the setting
i did put it on high you why
i just wanted to do it oh okay well
don't blame it on rebecca my wife wanted
me to do it
and um i put it up to my throat and it's
amazing i mean if you see in the video
so that's real
that reaction
wow
i for those of you who haven't seen it
jerry who is a very it was a large man
uh robust muscular
it he you go down you fall down like a
sack of potatoes
you lose you lose the ability to stamp
wow
wow
would you think of c that's right but
just not to upset any of your listeners
we did not put it on our animal at all
after we did that we threw it away
we did not use it yeah most of our
listeners love dogs
i know i just don't want anyone i know
saying like how dare you do that no no
you purchased that i noticed we're
dealing with the police the police were
coming to our house wow really yeah and
and what did they say when the police
come are they like
uh you guys have to get your dog
complaint what do you want you know i
mean i i mean i i can't believe i'm
saying this but i kind of get it like i
get it too i'd be annoyed living next to
you i would like it because it'd be fun
to visit with you but um
listen
the dog was driving all of us crazy oh i
bet i bet so what are the cops what's
the typical conversation
because everybody's here but my wife has
a little bit of a problem
how many do you have now
why am i whispering i don't know it's
not a legal amount so i don't even want
to say it oh wait like 15. it's like
like show exotic style
it's not a legal amount
oh it's not illegal
i don't think there was a legal amount
what's the legal amount of dogs
what
my ex-girlfriend had seven
maggie but they were rescues
i thought that made it okay
yeah maggie had seven dogs
big dogs [ __ ]
so listen we're like kind of technically
fostering some of them oh okay
but it's a whole thing because i go to
work and then my wife says oh my gosh i
have to go pick up this dog in riverside
it's about to be put down
and then i beg her not to get it
people can still hear you even though
you're whistling i know i i think you
just i know who are you trying to
prevent from hearing this
your wife
oh oh oh okay yeah
okay well maybe she'll listen to this
i like that that's what you think we do
where do you where do you do these
i don't know if i'm gonna make this
listen i mean obviously
obviously people are struggling and our
prayers with everyone who is struggling
and thank you to the doctors and the
first responders thank you thank you and
the people who work at the supermarket
thank you
it's rough how's teaching going
yeah you're now a teacher how's that
going
it looks funny from what you posted
i do find myself getting very frustrated
and yelling at my children
like simple tasks like they're going
through conversion i guess we call it
where they're trying to make like
milliliters into liters oh it's that you
know it's all like word problems
yeah
of orange juice how many liters does he
have yeah
my kids just don't get it and
you know i've even taught them
i know you're not supposed to do this
but i thought that like you can just
search this on the internet
like we're not in school anymore you're
homeschooled now
are they on the same level learning-wise
the answers are right there
and they still don't i have one daughter
i mean i love my kids i do
but i have one daughter who's like the
answer is right in front of her like
she's actually google's like
5 000 milligrams equals how many liters
and then the answer comes up and really
google is really good about putting it
in bold it's the first thing that comes
up
it's usually in a box
and i have one daughter like let's say
it says like
johnny has 6 000 milliliters of
cranberry juice how many liters does he
have
and my daughter will write that whole
thing into
google
and six liters will come up
and my one daughter will be like four
and listen i'm sorry i know you're not
supposed to do this
i have to yell at her at that point she
needs to be yelled at well you have to
be if this were a workplace
you hr
yeah and then then you'd have to deal
with hr
it's not a workplace though no it's a
school yeah it's a school workplace it's
funny because we are you know you do now
that we're all isolated this is a whole
thing
um actually um one of our dogs is hr we
like my kids have been going over to one
of our dogs
one of our smarter dogs
like the basset hound
bernard very smart oh they are very
smart right yes wow
that's not the one that was um barking
that's not the one that was barking okay
the one that was barking is sadly in
doggy heaven oh well that's nice for the
dog uh so you guys are just home the
whole time you're home
you're doing it you have breaks like
this you get to do i just saw you
talking to the e guy on canadian was
that e news oh you know what's so funny
is um they couldn't hear you they you
were frozen
i got a lot of great response from being
on your show i even hear
uh on the last episode when you tried to
call me and it didn't oh yeah that was a
hit that was a huge hit this is give
this must have given your career quite a
boost
well it is pretty funny uh for those who
don't know justin and christian tried to
call me last time i did agree to be on
last the last episode yes but we had i
had switched up i didn't done the
conversion i should have been taking
your class your conversion class because
i didn't convert the east
and i'm here in los angeles with my
family on lockdown yeah i i didn't do
the west coast east coast conversion
yeah
next to my phone staring at it
that's not true but it's a funny
favorite it's a funny visual suddenly i
texted you i thought maybe you guys were
like bantering you know in the beginning
of the episode how the two of you banter
the christian american banter yeah
and
um it it just didn't happen and finally
i threw in a text like what are we doing
well you know what's funny and this has
happened to me before we're like this we
were just on such different pages but i
i was on the other side of the country i
was getting a little frustrated that you
that you weren't picking up the phone
later
you know what i mean when we when we
were actually when i thought we were
supposed to do it so we were just on
different pages but there's a three-hour
time difference but we worked it out we
worked it up we're still friends it's
like the time we get out of that fight
in new orleans um you know i've been
noticing
for those who don't know where they
listed the last episode justin christian
and i got into a pretty big fight as
friends
it was a blow up by the way you know
chris it was on a movie called the look
like and christian just started watching
that movie for the first time last night
christian uh uh helped your
producer on the producer on it and tried
to rewrite the script um
uh which they were yeah you know it's a
good film it's not bad it's not bad yeah
you're very good in it i went to the
premiere that you guys did not come to
that i went to um
so
i do recall a story that you guys i'm
gonna out you right here and you can cut
this out it is your podcast you guys did
it was petty in retrospect i mean that's
the thing that you know this crisis is
also having that effect on me which is
i'm i'm evaluating choices that i've
made in my life and like some of which
now seem very petty uh compared to
things that are daddy you know what's
funny is um when i was a younger man
insignificant um
i used to argue with with people at work
yeah and
i i always it's so funny um
i used to always argue with
a superior
there was one superior who would tell me
what to do it sounds like it would drive
me crazy
and i would um
i would not only fight with them
i mean this is what a maniac i
i mean em
but it would
make it my mission to make fun of that
person behind their back as much as i
could
i am dying to know who this is this
place i think i know it's not hey listen
it's not one person it's a group of
people
[Laughter]
and
the couple's therapist immediately
looked at me and said you need to go see
somebody on your own
your problems man oh and did you go see
somebody
and
i mean
almost like right away the therapist i
was seeing pointed at pointed out what i
was doing oh wow wow now our fight makes
more sense
oh someone a superior would tell me to
give me an order and it would drive me
crazy
and i would make it my mission to oh
interesting i wonder where in childhood
that came from did did they take it take
it far that far back and did they
pinpoint where it came from oh no i
stopped paying at that point once i
figured that out
it's like who cares where it came from i
mean i'm good
yeah well that's why that will that
explain christian just said that
explains the fight that we got into
because technically on that job that we
did we were producers we were
technically
you're you're superiors
[Music]
[Laughter]
did i not make it my mission you didn't
annoy you you did you did like your dog
did with your neighbors you came to our
house and you like rang the bell and you
yelled and it was like you were
serenading us without the romantic stuff
yeah you were like john cuse i can say
anything a movie that i just rewatched
recently
and genuinely frustrated and scared and
scared
um all right we love you buddy take care
take care of
is
the
family
yeah that's it it's a check it's a
checking episode
guys no you can't do this to me i'm like
i need well
what else do you got what do you what do
you what do you need
where do you go talk i need to
how do you how did charlie and dolly
feel about you filming them for
instagram do they ever get like no dad
um you know what they're on like tick
tock and stuff oh right right what is
tick tock tick tick tock is mostly a
dance thing right what is it like it's
almost like vine it's like uh remember
yeah yeah
they're like short things i bet i'd like
it um
it's like instagram but it's uh
it's video i guess i've only seen dance
routines on tick tock maybe that's what
i thought it actually brings up an
interesting
celebrity thing
you know it's funny a lot of my
celebrity friends
put things over their kids faces oh yeah
yeah i would do that like michael
jackson well michael jackson did that
all the time they don't put masks they
actually like through like um yeah like
emojis post production but i meant to
say like
on like instagram
they put like patches are you about to
burp
huh were you just about to burp
no oh you you changed your voice like
you were about to burp i thought no i
did just eat so yeah actually there was
food at the top
for a second
um i wouldn't burp
that's okay if you do i do um um
but um
i can tell you it's a little weird it's
almost like
the ring it's like covering uh-huh it's
like like they don't fully exist but i i
understand the reason behind it i did
that with my when i posted a photo of my
nephew i didn't want
to i don't know it wasn't my it's not my
child like
i didn't want to do that to my
brother um
you know i'm in my 40s i'm a dad
my kids are as much a part of my life
yeah no that makes sense that makes
sense i get that
and it's funny with instagram like
it's it really is kind of like just me
sitting around and
taking a funny video oh yeah no jerry
i'm not like judging you for if i that's
one of the reasons i want to have kids
is to use them in business
i'm actually not not defending myself
i'm explaining why i do it yeah my
children are and this is the difference
i
mean
this is just what it is they're a part
of my life now yeah they're me yeah so
if i were to put a patch over their
faces it would
be weird as well
i get it i get it yeah um oh man it's
been funny with this car
watching um
some people on instagram i mean it's so
funny i wish i had the nerve to tell you
who's really annoying me on this oh i do
too oh my dad's
calling um
yeah i know i do too i i well will you
later cause i'm curious
um
i i don't want to mention them no no
don't do it now of course yeah
no i know but it's just
it's really crazy to see
how people react to not being around
people for a while i know well
everyone's climbing the walls and and uh
how were i know i and some of it yields
like really funny content god i just
discovered jack black on instagram he
had the funniest thing he posted just
from dancing around but how are your
kids handling it i mean they're teenager
almost teenagers like i always when i
was a teenager i always wanted to get
out and like be outside and yeah this is
the only good um this is the only good
thing to come out of this craziness
um
is my kids are 11 so they're just like
sort of preteen oh right they're just
getting ready to
hate my wife and i yeah yeah they're
just getting ready to not want anything
to do with us
you know and it's that very awkward age
of life where you can't drive anywhere
but but you're stuck
right right where
your parents have to drive you
to your social engagement that's right
it's actually it's like
i could i mean i don't i can't speak for
anyone else but my first feelings of
despair were at that age when
i was trying to date girls
and my parents would have to drop me off
yeah
well it's it's probably different in new
york i mean you grew up in new york city
so it was probably a lot easier
but a lot of my childhood was spent on
long island and my parents were you you
know my parents they're kind of bohemian
we had a very old
rickety car
and when they would drop me off on dates
it was real
i mean i gotta tell you like my face is
just getting flushed a little just
thinking about it when did you start
going on dates see i didn't start really
going on dates until i had a call i
could drive
i didn't know well you were also into
frogs and stuff
i was a later
bloomer by the way i did want to say
this to all of your fans yeah um
if you ever want to send christian
anything or any sort of like tokens or
anything i mean we know from listening
to this from the david uh harbor uh
episode
um
you love frogs you always have you do
yeah i do i do justin justin
justin is collected looked at
drawn
i love him yeah i know you're
yeah and you still do i still do i love
them i love their the sound they make i
still just the other day i took a walk
um
and i i walked by uh a pond that i used
to go to when i was a kid and i saw a
couple i'm glad you listened to the
david harbor i know that was my take
away from what you just said i know part
of you is trying to shame me a little
bit for still being into a juvenile
thing like
catching frogs but um
i but i i'm not just i wasn't saying
that at all
you know what that's actually not a bad
idea i would like a picture of that i i
i would enjoy a picture of somebody with
a frog that's why i'm saying it i don't
know why you immediately all right
sorry
no
you just explained myself oh yeah
yeah i wasn't being defensive i'm
explaining myself
i'll never forget when you and i where
we first met when we did a broadway show
you could listen to the old episode of
this and hear about it but justin and i
were on a show together and i sat next
to justin's mom and dad when he was i
think in some sort of rehearsal
situation and i wasn't in the scene
and it was my first time meeting him and
i went out to the audience and i went
hey mr and mrs long i'm jerry i work
with your son i love them blah blah blah
and they went hey and they were watching
you on stage and i sat next to your mom
and your mom said to me this is so
incredible to watch him up there
seems like yesterday he was just young
justin
so into frog
you were so excited to come back and
report that at rehearsal in front of
everyone
thank you for that
and the next day as soon as he could
jerry had to announce it to everybody so
you know justin loves frogs i don't know
if you all knew that
um you love that little tidbit all right
buddy i better go we have to call our
doctor friend too
but we love you okay right
do do thank your doctor love you okay
love you too
wow
couldn't get him off the phone oh i just
got back um oh thank you for these
christians just brought me some
some goldfish not pizza flavored which
they were out that wasn't an option um
according to our friend who shopped for
us was very nice
okay now we're gonna call our
doctor friend dave this will be more of
a check-in he is a pediatric emergency
medicine doctor in new york city oh dave
hey oh hey sorry sorry i don't know what
happened um
can you hear me
well i knew that i knew i called you
uh we are checking in dave you are on
life is short and um
you are
you're our only expert uh so we're
looking we've ever had yeah i think you
are that we've never held okay so no
pressure but we're looking to you to
single-handedly tell us what to do
excellent i got this okay this is a this
is a no
no big deal um but dave has been helping
us out as we've uh especially maggie
christian's girlfriend because she
really had the worst of it and uh he's
been guiding us through this and
we've been hearing about this new test
this like five-minute at-home test that
anybody can take they test their
a patient's person's plasma i think
and so they can determine whether or not
you've had it or if it's been in you and
how it's living in you do you have
antibodies if you have antibodies for it
uh uh yeah so um
there's been a lot of talk about that i
know our hospital is in process of
developing one that should be you know
fda emergency approved soon i believe
mount sinai some other places around the
country have similar tests
um and i think with any test you have to
just be mindful of two stats
two statistics about it so one is how
sensitive is the test and that means
that you don't want to miss anything you
don't want to get a negative test but
you actually had it right and then the
other is how specific is it meaning that
if it's positive can you be sure that's
what you have or is there cross
reactivity you wouldn't want it to be
positive but it's really positive
because someone had the flu you wanted
to be specific to coronavirus so
the thing is that there's a trade-off
between those two no test is perfect so
sometimes the more sensitive you have
then the less specific it is and vice
versa
and so sometimes they might develop two
staged approaches now in terms of the
immunity from what i'm hearing so far if
you have if you're showing immunity to
it like that you've had it in your
system that's fairly specific it's not
gonna show up if you haven't had that
virus so then you could be assured that
you probably were exposed
but if you don't have it it doesn't mean
that um
it still doesn't mean you weren't
exposed because it's not very sensitive
that's
so
so it's not
i i didn't quite understand the last
part you said if you have had it it's
not necessarily going to show up but why
just because it's not the test itself is
not sensitive to detecting those
antibodies
well so i'll put it this way like if the
test is negative it does not rule out
the fact that you've had it oh huh
interesting okay but if it's positive
means you definitely definitely had it
if it's positive okay well right now
right now the stat the the trade-off
between that sensitivity and specificity
is more favoring the specificity so okay
if you if you test positive you had it
it is is it more of a sure answer okay
nothing's perfect even even in that side
of it right okay well that's good to
know hopefully that'll change
the way people are now going to
reintegrate into
society when this is over um
one of the fundamental things about it
is for example in our workforce who are
you know on those front lines every day
yeah and dealing with their own you know
protecting themselves and their own
families amidst a real you know
terrible crisis of ppe shortage which is
the personal protective equipment it'd
be really nice to know that you could
have teams of people who were already
exposed and immune
you know doing some of the more risky
type of exposures
absolutely you know we're keeping your
other people a little bit further back
absolutely god that would be that would
be a huge
uh step forward
um dave where where can people donate um
you say there's a shortage of ppe are
there any organizations that you're
aware of that where you're being
supplied things that normally you
wouldn't be in term like ppe and other
equipment
yeah so actually um
it's been um there's been real
outpouring of support and so i feel like
we're starting to catch up to that in
new york between donations between the
hospitals figuring out sourcing
themselves between coordination with the
state and the city and of course all the
sort of hobbyists doing 3d printing um
there's a website called
getmepbe.org which is a nice centralized
one that was started by
some people with an emergency medicine
and that sort of coordinates things
great get me ppe.org
okay um all right and how is your at
your hospital how how are things looking
now i mean how dire has it gotten
so i i think the the the general
prevailing wisdom is we're we're
certainly not out of the woods yet we
have not hit our peak based on the
modeling
um
they're they're some of the world's
leading experts here in our school of
epidemiology who have done great uh
statistical modeling of it and in
essence like we're always going to be
two weeks behind understanding our
impact so anything we do today we won't
know how it will impact us for another
two weeks
so you know but basically based on the
curve and how it's been um it's still
climbing we're preparing now for
a couple of uh a couple more weeks of
sort of it getting worse um but i have
to say the cities and the state's
response and the hospital's response has
been uh
really incredible um and they're sort of
preparing for for the worst setting up
uh field hospitals and and uh ventilator
units so that we can hopefully deal with
this
and and dave for anyone thinking well i
i have a strong immune system i don't
have to really you know worry i can i i
don't have to quarantine myself or or
stay at home socially distant distance
myself uh what would you say to them
what would you say to people listening
who are
maybe hesitant to trust the scientists
or is there any talking
you know it's um i think that it is
important and
to understand human behavior and human
nature and you know people are cooped up
and um
you know it certainly doesn't make sense
that you know why can't i go outside
yeah you know there is agency in it so
i'd say people you know um what you're
doing is you have a choice of whether
you want to infect someone else or not
right now um the good news is i don't
want people to panic or worry i think
most people statistically are you know
there's a there's a large proportion
that have it that don't even know oh
yeah they're just asymptomatic carriers
and i and what's you know a little scary
is that you know people younger who with
no other health complaints or other
problems are sometimes the ones that are
really deteriorating quickly so you
don't know who it's going to get but
most of us will be fine but i would say
if you love your parents and your
grandparents and your friends with you
know
comorbidities and other medical problems
then and you don't want to see them die
then and you don't want to give them the
disease you should be staying home and
hopefully that's a hundred percent of
the people listening
i'm hoping
um i hope i hope everyone
yeah
you know it doesn't care about cities
states politics red or blue countries
yeah you know it's a pandemic that means
the whole globe and it requires a pan
response from all of us to sort of be on
the same team
and
to beat this thing well um dave i can't
thank you enough for being on the front
lines of trying to beat it and for
uh sharing that with us and and just
personally like helping us the last few
weeks dave's been um just texting with
us and helping us get through a really
scary time so
i my my deepest deepest gratitude to you
and everyone you're working with over
there
well i'm very welcome and thank you to
you too you know we're all playing our
part and we truly mean it when we say
thank you for staying home and thank you
for for you know lighting the mood and
giving us some comedy and a release uh
from all the news i would say mental
health is important too now and yeah
people should be doing some social media
distancing in addition to just social
distancing to give themselves a break so
you're saying that uh we're doing the
real work chris and i are doing the real
uh
yeah yeah okay
um thanks buddy i i appreciate it dave
thanks any time guys okay all right take
care of yourself stay safe
okay um uh-oh
hello
sorry i hate you
what happened with the fight
just my daughters
they're just with each other all the
time you know
i have twin girls when they're together
they become diabolical
my kids are really [ __ ] up yeah but
you and you and you and rebecca have a
mischievous very like mischievous sides
i try and squash that stuff immediately
you know
um i'm playing saxophone really
yeah oh my god you know what let me i'm
gonna try something on you okay can you
hold up one second i don't know i don't
think
can you oh yeah yeah yeah get you only
if you get your saxophone
sorry to our audience um funny because
he wanted he wanted to do it so fast i
know he called by the way a little back
story to this whole
this has become the
new jerry o'connell episode but the
backstory of this was he called us and
texted first called and said can we do
it now i got to go really quick i have
things to do he made it sound like
he said all right 15 minutes he wrote
how about seven minutes yeah he wanted
to do it faster hey yeah we were just
talking about how you uh about an hour
ago were like chomping at the bit to get
this done and really wanted to go
now you're bringing out a saxophone
okay listen
tell me
what
i've been practicing a song okay i'm
very new wait wait wait wait can i ask
you how long be prior to this had you
played the saxophone did you play it
when you were a kid and you picked it up
not at all oh you just picked it up for
the first time
yeah but i'm like trying to like touch
myself you know be really funny if you
just started making awful noises into my
photo or if you're like kenny g
what song this is i'm really working on
it okay okay okay yep
[Music]
um
[Music]
god
but it's not he didn't just play a kenny
g album
it's the one that the sax man and that
viral video plays
what is that song um
you know it do you want to hear it again
no
no that's all right i know it i can i
know the melody now
it's the famous it's a oh [ __ ]
[Music]
let me play it again and maybe you can
hear it i i i know this song i just
forgetting the name of it oh god
i don't want to hear that again
well how many listeners do you think
we've lost
that last part
oh yeah that last part got messed up uh
sex
i'm just googling because it's a famous
sax song
i i know it's a famous one it's the one
see if it comes out it won't careless
whisper
yes
yeah careless whisper
wow
that's george michael that's my news
george michael i couldn't think of the
name uh jerry we love you uh we're gonna
put you out
oh yeah do you mind
yeah we can use it at the end of the
episode yeah
go
ahead just hung up on him
[Laughter]
it's so funny knowing what that song is
like what it's supposed to sound like
now so it's funny to listen to his
version
uh yeah it's cool that he's teaching
himself yeah are you doing anything like
that
uh no i'm just trying to get my chest
feel healthy again yeah
um i've been but hopefully once i'm
better yeah i will it would be fun to
learn a new project you know i have been
wanting to get my cello restrung oh you
should well oh it's that mom and paw's
house on paws
don't i don't want to go anywhere i
don't go anywhere yeah so uh i kind of
missed the boat yeah we talked to dave
who whom you just all heard from and uh
he said once the symptoms were done
uh you gotta wait 72 hours before going
out um but now
that we're even doing that or i don't
know i i feel like
they keep revealing new information
about this this virus that like even i
don't trust the old
i i i i just think it's safer and
smarter to play safe and stay home
longer yeah good i mean definitely me
because i'm still uh yeah
you know i'm not 100
yeah i am back to uh
full health you seem fine i'm fine but
um
even so i don't i don't we we don't know
for sure that we had it so i just don't
want to risk going out unless i have to
unless it's a grocery store or something
and um
and in that case i heard it's um it's
good to wear a mask um not necessarily
because it prevents the germs from going
in but again
who knows for sure but uh more so that
you you're reminded not to touch your
own face that's a that's the big thing
let's read a letter and wrap up this
special yes very quick second it's been
turned into an epic quarantine check-in
um okay this is from allison this one
yes okay i'm going to read this letter
from allison w subject is quarantined
advice from mom
hello brothers long
as a stay-at-home mom of a seven month
old i am incredibly lucky and honestly
feeling a bit guilty that my current
quarantine days are not actually that
much different at all than my
pre-quarantined days
although i don't have wild stories to
tell everyone about being cooped up i do
want to share my favorite quarantine
advice from my mom for anyone feeling
panicky and stuck in a loop that's great
any mom advice i feel like is good um
it actually applies to lots of moments
in life when things get you down and you
find yourself wallowing in your own
troubles quote change your pants change
your mind
end quote i know it's the same simple
idea as the more popular wash your face
advice but there's truly something about
taking off the sweatpants and putting on
the jeans that says i got this
simple but effective to start fresh
that's good advice and now to gush a bit
oh um finally
uh thank you for being out this is very
nice and embarrassing to read but thank
you for being such a funny lighthearted
podcast i love the band between you and
i often laugh out loud and rewind to
listen again that's really nice thank
you allison and i am close with my
sisters especially my twin oh you're
just talking about twins and you guys
are so relatable my husband and i named
our daughter after our beloved late
grandmas so the grandma jody episode is
especially near to my heart she's a
treasure
she is you know we agree uh i can't wait
for the quarantine episode i am sure
people will have much cooler
conversation topics than me but i'd be
remiss if i didn't at least throw my hat
in the ring for listener calls
and she leaves her number
and if we hadn't talked to jerry for uh
eighty percent of the show we would call
her uh i'm always on the ready to chat
on my favorite show show of all time the
golden girls oh yeah i'm dead she says
i'm definitely a dorothy hey christian
or beautiful girls uh a movie that we
also love which i am pretty sure i still
own on vhs somewhere in my basement we
do still own that oh my god she's a
dorothy and she loves beautiful girls
yeah right up our alley wow um
when the dust settles and we can go back
out i look forward to more instagram
shopping videos ah
yeah i look forward to making them
thanks for being such a bomb
during these strange times how did she
spell bomb
b-a-l-m oh good
a bomb i like that word uh take care
allison in milwaukee oh if i had known
that i would have read that in a
milwaukee accident oh too bad right yeah
let me go back no it's okay it's a
stay-at-home mom
sorry that's more minnesota yeah uh what
instagram shopping video uh the ones
that i don't think maybe you didn't see
those i did them on my stories where i
went to
like when we were shopping sneaky peeps
yeah well this is a while ago when we
were like christmas shopping oh i kind
of remember you remember that yeah i do
you remember taking the things did i
take the videos maybe some of them yeah
i miss doing those
uh but we can do some at home and um
wow oh this is nice maybe we could read
this one next time yeah i like uh i like
that advice that's good advice it is
putting pants on yeah put pants on yeah
and that always makes me feel better yes
there's something about like wallowing
in your
pajamas that is
can really get depressing it can be a
real when it's it can be a treat when
you're used to wearing pants usually but
in times like this when when many of us
have been home
uh i've i found myself wearing
especially when you know when you're not
feeling well you wear pajamas all day
and it
yeah it makes it i mean for the first
few days it's one thing but now that
this has become
a new reality for us for everybody yeah
then i i think that makes that advice
change is true change your pans change
your mind uh that's great thank you
allison or i should say that's good too
changing your mind is good too i don't
know what's best well she's no no she's
saying it goes hand in hand pants and
pants it's change your pants it'll
change your mind
oh oh oh yeah yeah the one will be get
the other oh
can you just beget in a non-sexual way
yes oh okay uh
what a crazy question
it's normally used in a non-sexual way i
was just thinking biblically how they
use it but i think also changing your
mind encouraging yourself to change your
mind about things is a healthy thing too
forget the pants yeah yeah you know what
i mean well it's instead of like getting
out of the rut of your so don't wear
pants at all you're saying
i think they're separately it's they're
nice together those two things but i
think separately it's nice to change
your pants but also it's nice to change
your mind about things too uh well yeah
i also like the idea that some i think
what she's saying is something as simple
as making a change like i get it
but i'm saying let's forget the pants
for a second i think it's also nice to
change your mind about see you're trying
to have uh both things you're trying to
keep your pajamas on and be able to like
change your mindset i am wearing pajamas
yeah not pajamas i'm wearing that and
describe them to the audience uh they
are black oh i thought you're wearing
those they're like black sweatpants uh
with pockets that's not fun i thought
you were wearing those santa claus ones
then those are pajamas um
yeah thanks to allison's mom actually
change your pants change your mind when
when i first read that in the letter i
thought it was going to be about or
change your mind change your pants
yeah
well i i see i'm hung up on this that
one begets the other so the pants will
lead to a new mindset but changing your
mind might also help you change how you
change your past yeah i think i think
you can reverse it yeah
change your pants change your mind i
thought it was going to be like a
like
someone had peed their pants or
something
of course of course you went there
anyway
thank you guys for listening to this and
i hope uh that's really nice to hear um
that alan allison says we uh we've been
helping and we've been keeping people's
mind occupied with lighthearted chat um
so this was a little bit different as
you know these check-in episodes just
because we want to
you know we want to offer some
advice and and the fact that we have
access to a doctor and a very uh
impressive doctor he really is a really
good guy thank you to him for thanks to
dave for calling in and
that's really our brothers thanks to
jerry yeah yeah that's right uh dave is
our team college with our brother damian
yeah they went to princeton so you know
he's uh very qualified qualified yeah
qualified af as princetonians would say
um and as always thanks to our buddy
jerry yeah uh
and thanks to all you for listening um
and we will see you on tuesday tuesday
bright and early yes same time
same place uh
and uh thank you especially uh i i know
we've said it but it really bears
repeating i i think about it
all the time thank you to all of the
health care workers who are out there um
putting themselves on the line and uh
and to everyone who's continuing to do
the things that that
that
make our lives uh
you know livable and and relatively easy
so uh we are very fortunate uh that we
can do this from our home i hope if if
you're able to that you are also staying
home and i hope that you're also staying
happy and positive and healthy so thank
you all
see you soon
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
you